well since the passing of 49 year old
officer trong Tai we have learned who he
was as a police officer but today family
members are sharing are sharing with us
who he was as a brother and a son
Victoria Saha spoke with the officer's
family as they still come to terms with
his violent death with while on the job
Victoria
spending the morning with officer Ty's
family revealed what a humble person he
was and how dedicated he was to serving
this community he also protected his
family from knowing the day-to-day
dangers his job could bring and they
tell me they just celebrated his
birthday and are now planning for his
funeral
it was a very happy time we spent time
together with the help of a translator
KU Wang Tai is remembering October 6th
it would be the last time he would see
his son never thought of whatever would
happen happen we all now know him as
officer Thai but to his family he was
just Thai officer Ty was four years old
when his family immigrated to the United
States from Vietnam
really admired watching television about
police and he dreamed to be a police
since he was young a dream he turned
into a reality when he joined Metro 23
years ago the dead graduation
police officer then my family is so
proud officer Ty's sister Daisy Liu just
arrived from Hawaii despite the distance
she describes her six siblings as always
close even my best brother officer Thai
passed away last Thursday after
responding to a domestic violence call
police say Tyson Hampton fired 18 rounds
at tie and another officer one bullet
hitting officer Ty in the Torso I wish
that day if I can wake up and say I did
dreaming I wish I was there at that day
and hold his hand and say Ty we are here
for you and we all love you being killed
in the line of duty was always a fear
for Ty's family they tell me whenever
his late mom would hear of shots fired
in Las Vegas she immediately was afraid
for her son we always call him Thai okay
she said yeah I'm okay don't worry then
I we feel better but officer Tai never
wanted to back down you will not slow
down because beside him there's other
lives to take care to uh to save officer
Tai was 49 years old
officer Tai was working the graveyard
shift the morning he died it was his
shift of choice because it gave him time
to spend the day with his daughter who
his family says he adored I also asked
his father if it angered him that his
son's dream of becoming a cop ultimately
ended his life he said although they are
sad they are so proud to have a son who
gave up his life to Serve and Protect
Victoria Saha eight news now